to be honest I wonder if we're too
pessimistic because when I look at the
economic data uh you know the Friday
jobs report unemployment hit a 50-year
low like if you want a job
um it's it's still easier to find one
than it has been um at a lot of
different times over the past decade so
it makes me wonder like why are we so
pessimistic about the economy are people
too gloomy about the economy going into
2023 but again it's it's all such a wild
card I'm not sure if you heard Jamie
dimon this week say the FED has said
they're going to raise rates to around
five percent I think it could maybe be
six percent you know what does that mean
for the stock market we really don't
know
um
I mean that would that would be you know
tectonic so I've spent some time with
Jamie dimon
um and a number of years ago we came out
and said that the American economy is
not working for the average American and
we should come up with like a Marshall
plan to rebuild the account economy
which I appreciated from from Jamie
um he's been one of the more dour alarm
ringers uh recently and
Ray dalio was also the podcast and he
said something similar about the
American economy not working for the
average American if Jamie's right I mean
we'd be in for a very very rough go
because it would be uh you the only
reason interest rates would continue to
go up like that is if inflation just is
very very persistent and stubborn and
you can plausibly say hey if you have a
supply chain shock because of covet in
China like that could happen there there
are different Wild Card scenarios to
your point though right now more
optimism is creeping in because we've
gotten a couple of good data reports
lately totally and but I do want to I
think you bring up a really interesting
point about is the American economy
working for for the average American or
for the average worker and I think one
of the most fascinating Dynamics playing
out right now is during covid
the inequality was just on full display
right we saw the stock market soar to
new heights white collar workers were
sitting at home on their laptops on zoom
and you had blue collar workers out
there braving covid right
um and it seemed very unfair and I think
inequality was really just on Stark
display at that time
during the recovery after that brief
recession that we saw in 2020 I do think
what we've been seeing in the jobs
figures and in some of the wages figures
is just unbelievable demand for for blue
collar workers and I think they have a
lot more leverage
um than they did you know even a few
years back and I think in the past
downturns they were they kind of faced
the brunt of the layoffs and you know we
had the journal recently reported is
that changing is that Dynamic evolving
because I think what we're seeing is
that you know these big tech companies
are laying off workers where there's
still so much demand for for some of
those blue-collar jobs so I think that's
that's a really important thing to watch
in the economy in 2023 is how does that
evolve
foreign